the beyond challenging up next on book
TV afterwards this week the latest
release from Seth Jones hunting in the
shadows the pursuit of al-qaida since
nine eleven the rand analyst and author
of in the graveyard of Empires documents
the entire US war against al qaeda using
recently declassified information from
the CIA and the FBI as well as
interviews with current and former
officials of the US government this
week's guest host Associated Press
intelligence reporter Kimberly Dozier
Seth welcome to book TV and now is my
chance to ask you all the questions I've
wanted to ask as I watched your career
in the past few years you have time on
the ground in Afghanistan you've got
time advising the top Special Operations
commanders both here and in the field
and you've been in the think tank World
so let's launch with your new book
hunting in the shadows you talk about
three waves of al-qaeda violence and a
possible third wave before we get into
the evolution of how you've tracked that
how the US intelligence and national
security will distract that can we talk
about the health of the organization
we've just passed a major milestone with
the one-year anniversary of the Osama
bin Laden raid how are they doing well I
think how is al Qaeda doing depends on
which part of the organization were
talking about the core group based in
Pakistan that was led by Osama bin Laden
until he was killed a year ago that
organization has definitely struggled
somewhat it's lost a range of its senior
operational leaders religious leaders
and operatives but it has survived to
some degree it still has some key
founding members including Ayman
al-zawahiri involved in running the
organization abu yahya al-libi is now
the number two he's got a wealth of
experience in North Africa and a range
of other places so the organization at
the center has been
we can somewhat but I think it as we'll
talk about in a little bit when you look
out across its affiliates in places like
Yemen for example it is arguably
strengthened based on its levels of
violence its territorial control of on
the ground and a range of other factors
so part of the answer I think depends on
which part of al-qaeda in a group that
is clearly decentralizing so let's talk
about that evolution start is with the
first wave 911 what was the organization
like that and how were they able to
launch those series of attacks well the
first way begins group is formed in
Pakistan in the late 1980s and then over
the course of the 1990s begins to build
itself really as a hierarchal structure
pulls in a number of individuals and
groups from other locations but
particularly settles in Afghanistan
first in the Jalalabad area and then and
in particular bin Laden moves down to
the Kandahar area near near Omar the
issues for al-qaeda and what was going
right at that point where were several
things one had a sanctuary in
Afghanistan and it had an ally it had a
an individual mullah omar with whom it
had tents relationships at some point
but was a good enough host that it
allowed bin Laden to stay and a plan for
our operations it also had a somewhat
limited targeting structure at least for
the early period it was primarily
targeting US military facilities
embassies but not killing large numbers
of civilians so it targeted the USS Cole
the US embassies in Tanzania and in
Kenya and then as we got up to 911 it
became clear that there was really no
u.s. strategy at least one was executed
on the ground against al-qaeda so it had
sanctuary it had a limited selective
engagement strategy of killing minimal
civilians
and it had a an enemy who had not
identified it as a major threat I mean
had some people but the administration
general had not identified it as a major
threat so it was at that point seen as
an organization that had a means to
attack us abroad but not at home and
were they still just not taking it
seriously well there clearly were some
individuals we know even from the 911
Commission report and a range of
individuals I talked to it organizations
like the CIA including the bin Laden
unit at the CIA had that identified bin
Laden had identified grave concerns
about plotting attacks in the West
including in the United States we know
that a range of individuals like Richard
Clarke had were ringing alarm bells at
the White House level but again at that
point we go back and look the
administration at that point was focused
on things like the Balkans and Kosovo
war which was nineteen ninety nine so
issues other than putting out fires
elsewhere exactly national security
arena now you talk about this wave of
al-qaeda violence and then they get
beaten back sometimes because of their
own actions what caused the kind of
temporary defeat the first time was it
our launch into Afghanistan well it
actually it's almost the reverse of the
coin we just outlined they lost that
sanctuary in Afghanistan so the host
they had the Taliban regime was
overthrown and in addition to that we
saw a u.s. approach that was focused
mostly on clandestine services the CIA
the range of other intelligence services
NSA geospatial and then and then special
operations forces targeting in
Afghanistan and then in Pakistan and
other locations you're talking about in
2001 how the US fought back by sending
in CIA
and Special Forces Green Berets working
together on the ground in Afghanistan
with the tribal leaders and driving the
Taliban out in addition to what was
going on other locations so the capture
of individuals like Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed in Pakistan ramzi bin al-shibh
Abu Zubaydah not quite an al-qaeda
person himself but definitely involved
in operations Abu Faraj al-libi so these
operations even in countries like
Pakistan were done with clandestine
units working during that period closely
with the Pakistanis and then you know in
addition al-qaeda had in killing a large
number of civilians in New York City it
it did lead to a backlash in some areas
of the world especially among some
conservatives Sunnis that this was
probably going too far I was going to
ask you about that you go into great
detail in the book about the
intellectual debate back and forth
between Ayman al-zawahiri there's the
current leader of al-qaeda replacing bin
laden with his old mentor turned enemy
Shack Sharif in Egypt so you had two
former militants in arms who are
battling it back and forth can you
describe that yeah this is a really
interesting evolution of a relationship
Sharif and Zawahiri went back to the
early years in Egypt they were both
practicing doctors had both been
involved in the early years of the
establishment of Egyptian Islamic Jihad
had both gone to Pakistan together and
established a an e IJ that was becoming
a little bit more global and any
Egyptian Islamic Jihad that was becoming
a little bit more global in focus Sharif
ran the organization as watery was his
deputy Sharif was particularly important
because he he established a lot of the
important ideological underpinnings of
Egyptian Islamic Jihad
some of the stuff you wrote was used at
some of the al-qaeda training camps but
over the next several years they had a
falling out part it was
personality-based part of it was Sharif
was deeply upset at what as war he did
one of his books editing it in a way
that he thought was was wrong and then
it does appear that Sharif begins to
have second thoughts about the use of
violence in the way that sawari continue
to push armed opposition against the
Egyptian regime and then a just this
broadening view of killing civilians
including Muslims that Sharif ultimately
just could not accept as valid now you
talk about your frustration that the US
government didn't take advantage of that
schism between the two sides I how how
could the US have picked up those
messages and reflected them out to the
wider Islamic world without in a way
tainting them by backing them I know
that's a lot of a lot of times the US
officials are like well if we embrace
this person we just turned them into an
enemy of al Qaeda well I think the the
issue is less us getting directly
involved in most cases because I think
when the u.s. gets directly involved in
backing individuals including
conservative sunni muslims in this case
it tends to undermine them we take them
exactly we taint them I think the issue
rather is the the story the debate which
which spread among a number of global
jihadists who backed Sawaari and a
number of very conservative sunni
muslims clerics who backed suree for dr.
FATA laz he's often known I think the
issue was with one or two minor
exceptions most Americans and most
people overseas saw very little of that
debate so they you know there was one
article one or two articles in New
Yorker that Larry Wright wrote other
than that it was just buried and so for
communities in the united states that
were looking at over over the next
couple of years the works of individuals
like Anwar al-awlaki the many American
who is pushing out a kind of supportive
ideology we you didn't see a lot of
pushback because the stuff wasn't
generally translated made available it
was briefed around at all and i think it
was generally it was buried in this
broader struggle do you mean you think
that within the US government there
should have been greater awareness of
this debate back and forth or that the
US public might have changed their point
of view because of it or are you talking
about somehow trying to message it to
the wider arab world well i think all of
the above to make it clear to the media
that this debate was happening to in a
range of remarks that several US
presidents made both the current one and
the previous one could have at least
integrated the schisms happening about
al Qaida's use of violence you know one
recent or 11 really good case i think
along these lines was in the 2007-8
period where so our he pushed us out
these question says he's willing to take
questions from the ummah in across the
Muslim world and there's very little
discussion there's almost um B's writing
about it in in the u.s. is a really
interesting set of questions he gets
bombarded by Muslims across the world
with questions like why are you killing
civilians in all these locations in Iraq
in Algeria why are your organization's
killing so many muslims may that's a
useful discussion I think to have
publicly well I guess then I have to ask
we're just talking about the first wave
of violence at this point you got this
debate going on apparently the debate
didn't stop the second wave right
describe a second wave why did it take
off well the second wave so by 2003
al-qaeda
decimated we now know some of the
documents i cite in the book from
individuals like Sipho wattle who was on
the al qaeda senior Shura uh who is now
under house arrest in iran right well I
would but what what house arrest looks
like is a little unclear right now but
he definitely is he's believed to be in
Iran right now he's an Egyptian and it
was very close to Osama bin Laden
although after 911 in 2002 and 2003
becomes very critical of the
organization and is is from captured
documents we know he was very concerned
about the future of the organization it
had come under a major attack lost a
range of leaders but then comes the US
invasion of Iraq and in particular the
large numbers of American forces over
the next several years seemed to
encourage greater radicalization so part
of the book I spoke to a range of senior
leaders both at the CIA and at US
domestic organizations like the FBI I
was really jealous of your access by the
way I could tell people are answering
more of your questions than mine well
and also British intelligence so am i
five the domestic intelligence agency
individuals with whom I spoke said
there's no question that the invasion of
Iraq and the participation of a range of
nations like a British and the Spanish
hmm radicalized their own populations
and contributed among other things to
high levels of violence in Iraq but also
the the bloody attacks in Madrid which
al-qaeda was was was involved in at
least on the outskirts wasn't involved
in most of the operational stuff but
whose goal specifically was to get
Spanish forces out of Iraq and they
succeeded hundreds were killed in those
series of bombing right there were there
were multiple attacks on train stations
and in the next year in 2005 was over
London attacks gel Qaeda core
pakistan was intimately involved in and
again iraq loomed large over mohammad
sadeghi khan and the british Pakistanis
that were involved in that attack so so
each one of those attacks the people who
were available to carry them out had
were inspired by the iraq absolutely
inspired which was in part carried out
at least we were told at the time to
stop the spread of terrorism correct of
course later that was discredited that
you know that that there were only
tenuous connections between al-qaeda and
the regime of saddam hussein and the
weapon weapons of mass destruction turns
out to have been possibly a psy ops
campaign by saddam psychological
operations campaign to make countries
think he had weapons well I mean what
what becomes clear is and I document
this in one of the chapters is al Qaeda
in Iraq really does not form and become
an official affiliate that is they swear
by out or loyalty to Osama bin Laden
until late two thousand four so over a
year after the regime is overthrown and
by that point al Qaeda gets what it
hadn't really had for several years and
that is a sanctuary so provinces like
unbar they suddenly have a growing
sanctuary in two thousand four and five
and into 2006 so now this invasion has
radicalized a number of individuals
they're getting foreign fighters coming
through places like Syria into Iraq and
volunteering to serve the radicalizing
people across multiple continents and
also now they have a sanctuary in Iraq
so they've got a foothold in multiple
regions so this really gets us to the
peak of the second wave so we've got
both attacks overseas though not in the
United States plus we've got a series of
bombings that go on and on in Iraq led
by their cowie though his leadership you
explain is part of the reason that the
second wave started epping can you
explain how that worked and
that I know that also goes into the
whole Anwar awakening phenomenon and I
got to say no we're in your book do you
seem to say counterinsurgency was the
reason for the turnaround so sure
Zarqawi awakening counterinsurgency okay
Zack I was interesting because the
declassified documents between Al
Qaeda's core leadership in Pakistan and
Zarqawi show a very tense relationship
through 2005 and 2006 and as Zarqawi
continues to use brutal tactics like
beheadings and killing large numbers of
civilians through these big improvised
explosive devices car bombs al-qaeda in
in Pakistan we see letters from the
number two I meant also re the number
two at the time and also a tea Abdel
Rahman who was a serving as a deputy
general manager of al-qaeda sent a
series of letters to Zarqawi saying you
have got to stop killing so many
civilians especially Muslims including
yeah it is undermining your support you
also need to back off on targeting
civilians in other countries because he
had been involved in attacks in Amman
Jordan and he's and they both said you
are going way overboard and we're losing
support that's exactly what al-qaeda in
iraq began to do it began to lose its
support and provinces like unbar which
takes us to pre surge in in Iraq I would
say what you really see in 2005 and 2006
is less the large numbers of American
forces fighting al-qaeda in Iraq but
supporting Iraqis do it themselves you
know with with with special operations
with conventional army Marines and with
intelligence units providing a lot of
support but local Iraqis doing the bulk
of the fighting but the reason the local
Iraqis were doing the bulk of the
fighting was again Zarqawi's behavior
exam
I mean um and so he had not only been
sponsoring attacks against civilians but
can you walk us through some of the
things that he was putting the local
communities through I remember hearing
at the time everything from he's trying
to force us to marry off all of our
daughters to him he won't let us smoke
cigarettes and on and on well there was
one one awful case one that I put in in
one of the chapters of the book where Al
Qaeda in Iraq kills some local civilians
and as the tribal leader in that area is
trying to adjudicate to get the bodies
back al Qaeda in Iraq holds on to them
for well over the time period allotted
for in in general at least in that area
Muslim practice and they're rotting in
the street and then at some point after
a period of time the family is called to
retrieve the bodies and they have been
laced with improvised explosive devices
so as the family members are gathering
the rotting corpses in the street in
Anbar province they explode and kill
more members of the family and the
purpose from and out from the al Qaeda
in Iraq perspective was to teach locals
in this particular area lesson that they
were not to cooperate with a government
and they were not to cooperate with us
or other allied forces and what but the
reaction from local tribal shakes across
on bar because of events like this was
anger I mean a demonstrable anger where
you see by the fall of two thousand six
large-scale revolts against this kind of
brutality I made brutality that goes
well beyond you know basic dignity and
humanity and that that really causes the
population
and you're saying that's what drove the
local tribes to work with the Americans
that caused the awakening because we
were the only other tough guy on the
Block available to help them fight on
beat al Qaeda out and of course there
was the rise of Shiite violence inter
Shiite and Sunni violence at the time as
well oh they were I guess pinioned
between two enemies right well I mean at
that point al Qaeda in Iraq was killing
anybody who was not supporting its
broader effort to take more control over
especially the Sunni groups so it was
killing large numbers of Sunnis as well
and you know when you when we look at
some of the declassified documents it is
interesting by 2006 and 2007 as the
awakening starts to make inroads against
Al Qaeda and rock there are a number of
captured documents where you can see al
Qaeda in Iraq beginning to understand
what's happening they have lost popular
support their fracturing they're losing
members who are flipping sides people
are beginning to get upset about the
brutality so they begin to understand it
but in a sense least during that period
is too late so that is the second drop
the trough from the second wave what
leads to the third the third wave if
Afghanistan was the primary sanctuary
for the first Iraq the second the third
wave really hinges on among others Anwar
al-awlaki and what he did in a sense was
Mary several things up really quite
impressive from it from a strategic and
operational tactical level he was born
in the United States spent a lot of time
in Yemen had been a active as a mom in
San Diego and then in the Washington DC
area and then he goes to Yemen and he's
involved in starting this organization
al Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula
actually restarting because the they had
been
decimated by the Saudis in Saudi Arabia
gaining a sanctuary in late two thousand
eight and two thousand nine and and he
does several things that are that are
that are impressive at least from the
sense of getting the organization
started in Yemen he he uses social media
in the internet quite effectively he
puts out his sermons on the internet so
they're publicly available in English in
English and he speaks he speaks well he
speaks charismatic alee he speaks
actually not a lot of fire but he speaks
I mean if you listen to any of his
sermons it's you know he's persuasive
now he in it's interesting i looked at
some of the documents back in san diego
he was also the site of him that that
most people didn't see is he was also
arrested twice for soliciting
prostitutes in the san diego area so you
know there was clearly another side of
him that was different from the image he
was portraying but he also then gets
involved in operational and tactical
level stuff so in 2009 where would you
put him on a target list which put him
on a target list Umar Farouk
Abdulmutallab nigerian who had been
educated in London and then in Dubai
volunteers his services he had met allah
ki several years earlier volunteers of
services to conduct some sort of
martyrdom operation and as I walked
through in one of the chapters of the
book after reading a lot of recently
declassified information on it oh lucky
walks him through what he wants optimal
Talib to do and that is they've got an
innovative bob for him that ideally is
not going to get detected because it's
kind of metal in it so you can walk
through airport metal detectors and then
he and and then he says you need to
detonate this bomb when it's over
American airspace so his ability to
combine a strategy social media and
operations makes him a very potent enemy
really the linchpin of the third wave
even though initially County Sheriff's
experts who talked about him as being
inspirational not operational I guess it
took us a while to figure out where he
fit in that chain well it was clear I
think to the US government by late 2009
by December anyway after the failed plot
because he talked relatively quickly I
mean his bomb did not go it parsley went
off on the airplane but he then walked
through to the FBI in the series of
interviews what had happened it just was
never broadcast publicly so I think most
Americans were not entirely clear how
Milwaukee was involved operationally I
think you're right about that and you do
go into it in great detail now allah ki
of course was killed by drone strike
last September has when it al Qaeda
loses someone like that how long does it
take them to find a new candidate well
it's it's it's it's difficult in in some
positions one of the things that allah
ki was able to do better than most he's
inspire people I mean the magazine that
he and several others started called
inspire was useful but a lot of the
things he did helped radicalize now we
know that because a lot of the failed
and in some cases successful attacks
over the last several years in the
interviews afterwards with Major Hasan
for example afforded Ashish shooter he
was an email contact with a low key we
know najibullah zazi the individual 2009
was involved in the planning attacks in
new york city was an al-qaeda plot was
inspired by a lot of the fort dix
plotters in New Jersey inspired by
constants of jihad by allah ki so he was
able to do things that people like adam
gadahn the southern california
I operative who's he's an interesting
case I've got a part of a chapter
devoted him his father's Jewish he was
raised in sort of a Christian family he
ends up switching religions and then and
then joining al Qaeda going to Pakistan
he's broadcast on YouTube but they're
almost no cases i could find where
anybody is inspired by adam gadahn he's
he's a laughing stock in many places so
losing someone like that makes it very
difficult to replace so al Qaeda can
replace some of its operational
religious leaders but there are a few
people like allah ki where I think it
does take I think it takes time and they
may never at least in the in the short
term get somebody like that and of
course they also lost Samir Khan the
propagandists who helped a lackey build
those online magazines in this strike
last September that's right well after
the break we're going to come back to
Yemen and where it is in the third wave
and where the US says in fighting them
now thank you very much thank you
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through itunes and xml visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel so
we left off in Yemen third wave begins
inspired by Anwar al-awlaki
american-born radical cleric started as
a propagandist and moves into the
operational side of things why does AQAP
al Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula as the
M&E group is known present such a threat
to the United States you would think
okay a couple of bomb plots targeted at
airplanes but aren't they also focused
on a local fight I mean where do they
come down and why do we spend so much
time worrying about them now well
especially by 2009 and then into 2010 al
Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula was doing
both it was trying to expand its
sanctuary in Yemen in places like Shabwa
governor it where it had established
some training camps in the mountains
around the Gulf of Aden and also it had
some individuals like a lackey like
Samir Khan who were targeting interested
in targeting the United States and who
had some volunteers who were willing to
do that so that mixture was a
potentially concerning especially if
they could get people and inspire them
to do it so so targeting was almost part
of their recruiting process to it for
their overall organization I think
there's no question and so I mean
encouraging individuals like Major Hasan
the fort hood shooter to this a great
propaganda victory for them because they
could actually take someone who was an
American soldier
and it had doubts about he was about to
be deployed to Afghanistan had doubts
about being a Muslim in the US Army and
it could use that killing at Fort Hood
as an example of instability within the
what they call the the enemy and it was
a way to show that they were getting
some inroads within the United States it
looks to me that a lackey was not
directly involved in the operational
component but was certainly involved
through email contacts in helping
inspire him to do that so both targeting
directly but also inspiring individuals
they became a serious threat and then we
saw that a year or so later with the
plot that was an attempted to put
explosive devices into printer
cartridges so our go plane you know in
cargo planes that's exactly right and
what's interesting with al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula probably better than
any other al Qaeda affiliate by this
time is they were really innovative the
bomb that they they established for the
Christmas Day bomber thousand nine was
again one that they figured out how to
get it undetected in airports because it
had no metal components and they had
tested that bomb and it worked these
were that the plastic explosives that
were sewn into Omar Farouk Abdulmutallab
underwear correct and the only reason it
didn't work as the ignition didn't quite
go off correct and I it's I'm not a bomb
expert and it's so it's not entirely
clear to me why I know that with at
least one maybe even two km test cases
that bomb had actually gone on they
tested in Yemen I don't know if it was
they there was a decent amount of time
between when he had been given it and he
went a circuitous route from Yemen
through Africa stayed for a pair of time
in Nigeria then went to Amsterdam and
then the u.s. I mean that was the part
of the instructions from Milwaukee was
was to avoid detection as much as
possible and if
you go through these multiple locations
you stay for app along time in Nigeria
where he's from that he would avoid
detection which was she was but that may
have actually then had an impact on the
purity of the ingredients the powdered
ingredients with in his underwear bomb
but that innovation of thinking of how
to thwart security and how they've been
thinking even since then about ways to
thwart security processes through body
cavity bombs like used by one of the
AQAP Bombers to try to target remember
the Saudi royal fans act ly but even
even more recent plans that they have
been playing around with putting bombs
in cameras or other other items that
could be brought on to a airplane as
part of your your luggage that you know
for check in your carry-on so you're
saying they have the reason AQAP is the
face of the third wave for you is
because they have the means to go with
the aspirations to carry some of this
stuff out and it sounds like they're
they're still recruiting that's what I
keep hearing that they've there's Yemen
is becoming a place that's a real draw
for foreign fighters that's right so
well and in addition to that when the
arab spring begins to spread they also
get a government that begins to weaken
and they get a government that also is
involved in multiple insurgencies with
in Yemen so I mean in a sense as they
improve and increase their operational
capabilities they get a week weakening
government that has multiple
insurgencies that it has to deal with
and the that helps facilitate and allow
them to spread that sanctuary now there
was a bit of a debate going on though
between AQAP leaders and Osama bin Laden
before he died about which which way to
go with that fight can you walk us
through that well i mean my reading of
this is a
bin Laden and and some of this has not
been really discussed a lot publicly but
bin Laden did have some concerns about
several of its affiliates in focusing
too much on the the wars in the
countries they were operating it so
folks here and much on Yemen right and
and actually al Qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula was probably less of a concern
for him than was the islamic maghreb or
a raka because in Africa or in Iraq
because al Qaeda in Yemen was at least
looking overseas to conduct attacks
several the other affiliates were doing
very little activity outside of their
own countries and he apparently sent
several letters out to affiliates where
he said remember we need to attack the
United States so don't get so bogged
down in fighting in Somalia in North
Africa in Iraq and in Yemen that you
forget the far enemy that's the United
States so part of what bin Laden was
also trying to do is encourage them not
just to spread within their own
countries which was important but also
to continue to focus on the US now that
sort of brings us to Afghanistan which
was the start of this fight was bin
Laden's sanctuary and is currently where
tens of thousands of US forces are still
battling it out where did the fight on
the ground in Afghanistan go from being
the right war to something that helped
inspire these waves of violence well I
think one one factor was the decision to
go big in Afghanistan which is actually
less in my view a counterinsurgency
issue but to go big with large numbers
of forces and to focus on the central
government as really the only actor
involved so I would say through two
thousand seven and eight
even for most of 2009 the focus in
Afghanistan was deploying increasingly
larger numbers of American forces and
the problem with that is well in my view
there is among other things there is
variation in the competence of American
forces to do this kind of stuff I would
say you certainly have a special
operations component that's trained for
this kind of counterinsurgency irregular
warfare working with locals on the
ground was working in small numbers
that's right and we I would say you got
variations in the quality of
conventional forces in talking a
counterinsurgency game still trying to
fight this almost like a conventional
war living in not in local villages but
living primarily in fire bases
occasionally going out and conducting
operations but it was one where I think
was largely isolated and the second part
of it is also assuming that the answer
was really to build up large numbers of
national security forces in Afghanistan
afghanistan afghan national army and
police well i would say historically and
even if you go back to 2001 when you get
into rural areas i would say very
strongly there is no history recent
history said say the last 100 years
where local communities have ever
established security because of
permanent presence by central government
forces yet that was our answer for
several years to push out police
permanently into rural areas we didn't
have enough many locals didn't want them
so I think you push those things
together and it created a problem well
there is also something that you allude
to several times that we are your quote
is it's a war in which the side who
kills the most civilians losses now we
saw that working against Abu Musab
al-zarqawi in Iraq he killed too many
civilians there was a backlash in F
Stan frequently civilian deaths
inadvertently caused by NATO forces
makes far bigger headlines than Taliban
deaths or deaths caused by Taliban say
improvised explosive devices that hits a
school bus instead of the u.s. army
patrol it meant to hit so is that part
of your argument that because we had
these larger numbers of conventional
forces with varied ranges of competence
that they caused more civilian
casualties or is that is it less that we
we empowered a force of Afghans that
couldn't keep the peace well I think
it's less the civilian casualties front
because frankly when you when when I
spent a lot of time in rural areas I
mean they recognized pretty clearly that
the Taliban were killing a large number
of fact they were killing a lot more
civilians then NATO or Afghan forces
were doing no I think the issue was when
you go in big with conventional with
large numbers of conventional forces and
you go in and in a country that has
historically been dominated in rural
areas by tribal sub-tribe clan elements
and you try and go in with a central
government approach that combination of
big foreign and I would say a somewhat
inappropriate strategy combined to to
mean rural parts of the country we're
simply not being effectively stabilized
because nobody was operating in them no
conventional or special operations
forces in 2009 we're doing anything
permanent in rural parts of the country
there were no or very few Afghan
National Security Forces and and and and
in addition to that we see the
percentage of support for the Americans
start to decline because it looks like
it's a foreign government that is trying
to establish security on the ground for
the Karzai government that looks bad
over time I mean levels of support will
high in two thousand one and two but as
it becomes a major US presence to try
and secure
the Afghan government rural villages it
begins to look bad the government looks
incompetent because like we're an
invading force that is backing up our
puppet and telling them what that's
exactly what it begins to look like yeah
and I think that was a problem so that's
less of the argument you make and in the
greater war onyx violent extremism that
he who kills fewer civilian casualties
wins but more of a we got into
Afghanistan fighting one fight and it
morphed yeah well I mean you know part
of the issue with Afghanistan is that
war is not over so we're we're in the
middle of that one so I think they're
clearly have been periods where and and
and what the Taliban is done differently
than al-qaeda in many areas is while in
Iraq where we talked about earlier in
2005 and 2006 al Qaeda in Iraq was
killing large numbers of civilians the
Taliban though they killed more we're
actually quite careful a lot of the
Taliban killings even if civilians were
targeted assassination generally small
numbers of individuals they believed
were collaborators or family of
government officials or family of
collaborators so I would say what the
Taliban did not do is kill large numbers
of civilians in fact the numbers of
civilians in a sense compared to rock
were much lower in Afghanistan and they
were in Iraq so what I'm looking at is
from your argument about how we can
avoid a fourth wave how we behave or
handle the end of Afghanistan and how we
move forward in places like Yemen and
Somalia that could make the difference
as to whether al-qaeda stays around oh
and remains a threat to US national
security or becomes a footnote something
like something that you
irritant that you is always in the
background but doesn't require major US
investment and time so what would your
recommendation be let's first of all
talk about Afghanistan you in your
previous job where major proponent of
the Afghan village stability operations
program and the local police program
that goes along with that that is I'm
going to let you describe it but I got
to tell you it is every US official I
talked to they want to they want to
believe that that is the way forward
what is it and is it the way forward and
the way out well in terms of the village
stability operations in Afghanistan let
me just first say that there is no
silver magic bullet neither this program
nor anything else the US and the Afghans
and the Allies do is in and of itself a
silver bullet but I think what it does
is it's it's supplements and complements
efforts to provide security and
governance and development in rural
parts of the country now most of the
effort over the past several years has
focused on training national security
forces supporting a formal rule of law
that is through courts and then pushing
in development through Afghan ministries
formal ministries very top-down very
top-down what this program does is uses
a much smaller number of forces to
support local villages for at least
three major purposes one is help local
communities at the village level now
this is sending small bands of special
operations forces into these remote
areas that's right 12 Green Berets 12
Navy SEALs that's right and afghan
special operations teams type ok into
local villages to help locals provide
what they've done for thousands of years
and that is a basic community level
security defensive community level
security to
port in formal governance meeting in
most of let's just take pashtoon areas
of the country that is parts of western
southern and eastern and then pockets of
northern Afghanistan where rule of law
in rural parts of the country does not
come from a court or a judge it comes
from elders coming together and
adjudicating an individual that is
having a dispute with somebody else
supporting at least for the near term
that kind of adjudication informal rule
of law and then encouraging development
to come in from the bottom up so it's a
bottom-up component to a strategy that
historically was only top down so it
supplements it can't win or lose it by
itself but it was a component that I
think many people felt was missing for
several years and was certainly when you
look at periods of stability in
Afghanistan from say nineteen twenty
nine to nineteen seventy eight with the
success of Kings I hear Shah his father
nadir Shah though hon another relative
when they had established fifty years of
stability and that was pretty recently
had combined top-down governance and
security and development and and
supporting autonomy from the bottom up
among the tribes of tribes and clans in
rural parts of the country that strategy
the village stability operations sits in
is more along the lines of that was a
heben dynasty so that's working to use
the phrase of the Green Berets by with
and through the local forces and
establishing what a presence as long as
you need what else would you supplement
with what what else would you supplement
that effort with as we move forward if
you were designing our post-2014
strategy when we're supposed to have
stopped combat operations and pulled the
majority of troops out well first I
wouldn't stop combat operations I think
the footprint can decrease I certainly
would support
operations to help Afghans target
Taliban Akane and other insurgent groups
so I think stopping combat operations
would be a mistake I think the footprint
can decrease but i would say in
particular keeping a pretty decent-sized
Special Operations contingent they can
do more than just target but can also
train regular meaning national security
forces and irregular meaning the local
police forces and also working on
improvements in governance I mean things
like the kabul bank crisis that for a
long time went without any prosecutions
that stuff sends a message to a local
population i think supporting those
kinds of efforts to hold people
accountable are important and then the
key factor frankly over the long run
ends up being with a roughly week stayed
in afghanistan is its neighbor in
particular pockets pakistan before to
pakistan i do have to play devil's
advocate and say you know we've had tens
of thousands of troops diplomats
contractors on the ground trying to do
what you're describing for instance
trying to make the Karzai government
root out corruption amongst its own and
failing over and over and over how could
this smaller footprint force do that
well a couple of things one is we'll
have a new president shortly so I would
say it's an open question as to what
leadership will look like in afghanistan
in two years mm-hmm you don't think
Karzai's going to go for somehow
changing the Constitution to stick
around for a while well it's unclear
there a whole range of options that but
I think it does provide an opportunity
for putting in fresh thinking in
Afghanistan I mean any US president
that's had to go through two terms is
exhausted by the time that second term
is done so that's certainly one factor
that's going to change in the
foreseeable future plus I think if you
look at assessments of the
counterinsurgency
campaign over the last two years the
Taliban and i would say going back
especially to the south i would strongly
support these conclusions the Taliban
has definitely lost ground in key areas
including the south parts of Helmand
parts of Kandahar and I would say it's
much less the number of forces
international forces that are involved
in Helmand and Kandahar and much more at
least in places I've been supporting
local entities in those areas and yet a
recent national intelligence estimate on
Afghanistan said that there was still an
influx of Taliban from Pakistan where
they are sheltered and safe havens there
and that every time US forces or Afghan
forces withdrew from an area the Taliban
almost always flooded back in unless it
was an area in the north where they
didn't have an ethnic base but in the
Pashtun south and especially the East
that it's very hard to keep them from
coming back if you don't keep a presence
on the ground well but the president's
doesn't have to be just an American one
I mean I think the the the general trend
over the past two years has been areas
have largely been held I mean Arghandab
Kandahar is a great case it's a district
outside of Kandahar City symbolically
the most important city in Afghanistan
certainly in southern Afghanistan for
the Taliban aquare inner Shura was in
the 1990s Arghandab in 2009 was when I
was down there was an incredibly
dangerous place us Stryker brigades were
lost a number of individuals there you
go there now the security situation is
so much better now based largely not on
a huge American footprint but a much
better local police presence and a
national police presence that stabilized
much of the district and kept it that
way for now going on three years so I
would say there have been a range of
areas across key parts of the south
where we've seen the Taliban partially
pushed out and have stayed out now there
now whether I mean you're right
point out whether that can whether that
will be the case over the next two or
three or four years is an open question
I was is this a strategic pause on their
part are they just waiting it out in
Pakistan now let's talk about Pakistan
every time the US has turned up the heat
on militants in Afghanistan they've gone
next door according to the intelligence
reports that have been described to me
uh actually i would say i would put a
little differently I would say what one
thing that's been consistent over the
past several years frankly the past
decade is that the command and control
structure for the insurgency have been
and is and will be for the foreseeable
future in Pakistan so there has been
some targeting of some of the insurgent
groups in Pakistan the hawk Connie
network which is based in the tribal
areas and the al Qaeda elements and a
few others that sit in the tribal areas
of Pakistan but the the most important
Shura in my view by far is the senior
Taliban Shura all those other groups
have representation into that sure that
sits in Baluchistan province near
southern Afghanistan and there have been
no sustained us operations against the
Taliban leadership in Baluchistan or or
David yeah we're not allowed to go there
or were the Pakistanis and the
Pakistanis also again and again US
officials speak of how the Pakistani
intelligence service supports the
Taliban supports the hakan II network
and fund some of their activities
helping them attack US troops in
Afghanistan I mean with a partner like
that what do you do if you're saying I
mean al Qaeda proper is I keep hearing
hiding somewhere in the Pakistani
federally administered tribal areas the
Taliban you're saying is in Balochistan
we could leave a presence in Afghanistan
including the kind of hunting presence
that you also talked about that the
careful targeting of special operations
together with Intel
forces but if the enemy's hiding in a
country that you're denied operating in
as we are currently in Pakistan I mean
it's difficult for CIA officers to
operate in Pakistan what do you do well
this is the sixty-four-thousand-dollar
question so I would say even if you can
succeed to some degree in undermining
Taliban and other control in Afghanistan
you do have this big challenge with
Pakistan what do you do well you know
the most successful period and working
with the Pakistanis was after the
September 11th attacks that was with
Musharraf and that was a very good
relationship for several years but
unfortunately it almost took a September
11th type attack for the Pakistanis to
mean to see were serious and for us to
really mean we're serious in destroying
in that case a regime that they had
helped build so absent that kind of an
attack meaning an attack in the u.s.
homeland that comes from this region
where the US has to change a strategy I
don't see any other option than the u.s.
thinking very carefully about if it
really wants to eliminate the Taliban or
at least we can severely weaken the
Taliban which still has a relationship
with al-qaeda right now including senior
members of the inner Shura that it has
to either work with Pakistan to target
senior Taliban officials
war right I think you could fill in the
blank got it well with a couple minutes
left let's pull it back again to
al-qaeda at large the organization you
say has changed a lot since 2001 to now
so you're a short prescription if you
had to well you just were having some
chats at the White House what was your
30-second elevator speech on how to take
the next steps against al-qaeda well
there are a couple of things one is I
think u.s. strategy matters a great deal
and there are a couple of things I think
that would we want to avoid and as we
saw for example during the second way we
want to avoid a foreign policy decision
that will radicalize large numbers of
individuals to support al Qaeda like the
Iraq invasion so no more ground
invasions no more ground invasions and
and where that would come into play is I
think if there was a successful attack
on US soil some might actually call for
more of a presence in a weather is Yemen
or or Pakistan or another location I
think that would be and some of those
attacks in he was home I come very close
I'm doing Abdulmutallab in 2009 The
Times Square bomber 2010 we're very
close that would be one the other would
be to not do something like an attack
against Iran I think which would
probably also have the potential to
spiral and radicalize those are two
elements the third very briefly is the
u.s. is in this discussion right now
about moving east to the Asia Pacific
there's been a new DoD strategy
Department defense strategy which
focuses on moving east that the Asia
Pacific is the future I would just say
as you look across North Africa horn the
Middle East South Asia you see a range
of regimes that are weakening somewhere
al Qaeda has gotten a foothold and some
like Syria and Molly where it's
desperately trying that now is not the
I'm too real we're pulling Marines out
of Afghanistan and putting them into
Australia that now may not be the time
to move wholesale strategically to the
east so what you're saying is shrink the
footprint but keep an eye on the enemy
because it's still there I think you
said it better than I did well I have to
say this was one of the most
comprehensive histories of the last 10
years that i have read all in one book
and it was a good read so I'm great to
talk to you and thank you very much
thank you very much Kim
you